Narrator: TONIGHT, IN HONOR
OF VETERANS SMALL BUSINESS WEEK,
WE SALUTE
AMERICA'S ENTREPRENEURS
WHO HAVE ALSO SERVED
OUR COUNTRY.
I'M A FORMER
UNITED STATES MARINE.
HOO-RAH!
[ DOG BARKS ]
[ GASPS ]
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE ONLY MADE $375.
OOH.
HOW MANY DID YOU SELL
LAST MONTH?
PROBABLY LIKE 40.
HOW DID YOU EVEN GET HERE?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
THAT IS A BIG MISTAKE.
GO BEAT HIM UP.
LIFE IS FULL OF OBSTACLES
AND FAILURES,
AND WHEN WE FACE THAT,
WE DON'T GIVE UP.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT IT TAKES
LIKE A S.E.A.L. DOES.
THANK YOU FOR SERVING
OUR COUNTRY.
THANK YOU.
Narrator: AND LATER,
A SPECIAL MESSAGE
FROM OUR NATION'S FIRST LADY.
MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE THRILLED TO CELEBRATE
VETERANS SMALL BUSINESS WEEK
WITH ALL OF YOU AT "SHARK TANK."
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
MY NAME IS ASHLEY DRAKE, AND
I'M FROM LOUISVILLE, KENTUCKY.
I'M AN ACTIVE-DUTY OFFICER
IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY.
CURRENTLY, I'M A CAPTAIN WITH
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
IN 2007,
WE WERE DEPLOYED TO IRAQ.
I DID 15 MONTHS OVERSEAS.
IT WAS A VERY REWARDING
EXPERIENCE
BEING AT THE TIP OF THE SPEAR,
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHING MISSIONS.
AND I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT WE MADE A DIFFERENCE.
Man: LET'S GO!
FOR ME, PHYSICAL FITNESS
IS VERY IMPORTANT
NOT ONLY FOR MY CAREER
IN THE MILITARY,
BUT ALSO JUST TO STAY HEALTHY
AND THE BEST THAT I CAN BE
FOR MY FAMILY.
I WAS DOING A LOT OF TRAINING
TO STAY IN SHAPE.
KEEP GOING, KEEP GOING.
WHEN YOU DO
HIGH-INTENSITY WORKOUTS,
YOU NEED THE RIGHT GEAR TO
PROTECT YOU AND PREVENT INJURY.
Man: HOW MANY ORDERS
DO WE HAVE TO DO TONIGHT?
Drake: 100.
AS USUAL.
[ LAUGHS ]
THIS COMPANY IS GROWING FASTER
THAN I EVER THOUGHT IT WOULD,
AND WE CANNOT KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND.
WE BELIEVE IN THIS SO MUCH
THAT MY HUSBAND
LEFT HIS FULL-TIME JOB
SO THAT HE COULD TAKE ON
THE COMPANY FULL TIME.
PUSH, PUSH, PUSH!
WE NEED TO FORM A STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH A SHARK.
I KNOW THAT APPLYING THE YEARS
OF DEDICATION AND DETERMINATION
THAT I'VE LEARNED IN THE SERVICE
CAN REALLY MAKE THIS DREAM
A REALITY.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ASHLEY DRAKE,
AND YOU -- ALL OF YOU --
NEED TO GET A GRIP...
...THE NATURAL GRIP.
I'M SEEKING A $100,000
FOR 20% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
DO YOU WANT YOUR HANDS
TO LOOK LIKE THIS
WHEN YOU GET DONE WORKING OUT?
NO!
NOBODY DOES.
AND MY PRODUCT
PREVENTS THIS PROBLEM.
YES, THERE ARE OTHER
HAND-PROTECTION DEVICES
ON THE MARKET.
THEY'RE LEATHER, THEY'RE CLOTH,
THEY'RE NYLON,
AND THEY DON'T WORK.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY SLIP OFF
YOUR HANDS, THEY'RE BULKY,
AND THEY HINDER YOUR PERFORMANCE
IN THE GYM.
NOT THE NATURAL GRIP.
WE ARE THE ONLY CUSTOM
HAND GRIP ON THE MARKET.
OUR GRIP IS BASED OFF
OF YOUR RING-FINGER SIZE.
AND WE ARE THE ONLY
REUSABLE TAPE GRIP.
SO LET ME SHOW YOU HOW IT WORKS.
ONE OF OUR SPONSORED ATHLETES,
DANIELLE SIDELL,
WILL NOW PERFORM
THE CLEAN AND JERK.
SHE HAS JUST 165 POUNDS
ON THE BAR, NO BIG DEAL.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
TO WEAR GRIPS DURING THIS
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY CANNOT HAVE PROPER CONTROL
OF THE BAR
AND GET IT OVER THE HEAD SAFELY.
Man: WOW.
DANIELLE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT PROBLEM.
Greiner: WOW.
THERE YOU GO.
GOOD JOB, DANIELLE.
IMPRESSIVE.
SO NOW SHE'S GOING TO DO
SOME BAR MUSCLE-UPS.
NOW, BAR MUSCLE-UPS ARE
A VERY COMPLEX MOVEMENT.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT THEIR HANDS
START TO RIP AND TEAR OPEN
SO THEY HAVE TO DROP
FROM THE BAR.
NOT DANIELLE.
IN FACT, SHE'S ABLE TO GO
FROM THE BAR MUSCLE-UP
STRAIGHT INTO KIPPING PULL-UPS
WITHOUT ANY PROBLEM.
THAT IS NOT TYPICAL.
YEAH, YOU THINK?
WHY? BECAUSE HER --
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL, BECAUSE OF HER HANDS.
THAT'S WHY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE PROTECTED,
AND SHE FEELS SAFE ON THE BAR.
SO I HAVE SOME CUSTOM GRIPS
FOR YOU.
ARE YOU SAYING
IF KEVIN PUT THAT ON,
HE COULD DO
EVERYTHING SHE DID?
I MEAN, I'M NOT GUARA--
YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO?
GO BEAT HIM UP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ROBERT, YOU HAVE THE CUSTOM
DANIELLE SIDELL NATURAL GRIP.
LORI, PINK.
I MEAN, WHAT FEMALE DOESN'T
LIKE TO WORK OUT IN PINK?
KEVIN, THIS IS THE COLOR
OF YOUR SOUL -- BLACK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, YEAH.
DAYMOND, BACK TO YOUR
FUBU ROOTS -- RED AND BLACK.
AND MARK --
I MEAN, SHOULD I SAY IT?
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
Herjavec: ASHLEY, HOW
DO YOU PUT THEM ON?
YOU JUST PUT THEM OVER YOUR RING
FINGER AND YOUR MIDDLE FINGER.
AND THEN
HOW DOES IT ATTACH?
IS THERE A STRAP
THAT GOES --
WELL, YOU CAN ATTACH IT WITH OUR
CUSTOM NATURAL GRIP GOAT TAPE,
WHICH WE'LL SELL YOU
FOR $7 A ROLL.
I LIKE THE UP-SELL.
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
OR YOU CAN -- YOU CAN ATTACH IT
WITH YOUR OWN WRIST WRAPS.
SO WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO IS,
I WANT YOU TO PUT GIVE
IN THE GRIP.
SO YOU SEE HOW YOU KIND OF ARC
YOUR HARD LIKE THAT RIGHT THERE.
OKAY.
FEELS REALLY GOOD.
MM-HMM.
IT'S VERY FLEXIBLE.
ARE YOU COMING UP HERE
WITH ME?
YEAH, I'LL COME UP.
I'LL TRY IT.
I SEE A HERNIA.
EASY.
THERE YOU GO, ROBERT.
GOOD JOB, BUDDY.
YOU DID BETTER THAN I DO.
Drake: GOOD JOB.
[ APPLAUSE ]
O'Leary: THERE YOU GO.
HOW DO YOUR HANDS FEEL?
THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
THE GRIPS ARE AMAZING.
HE CAN GO ALL DAY.
Drake: THAT'S WHY SALES
ARE SO GOOD.
Cuban:
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
GOOD JOB.
John: GOOD JOB, ROB.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, SHARKS, YOU CAN RIP,
YOU CAN TEAR,
YOU CAN BLEED
ALL OVER THE PLACE,
OR YOU CAN GET THE NATURAL GRIP.
SO WHO'S READY TO STOP THE PAIN
AND SEE THE GAINS?
WHAT ARE YOUR QUESTIONS?
O'Leary: WELL, QUESTIONS
ARE ABOUT MONEY.
SO, YOU PUT A VALUE ON THIS
FOR $500,000.
THAT MEANS YOU MUST HAVE
SOME SALES OR YOU'RE CRAZY.
WHICH ONE IS IT?
I HAVE SALES.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, THE NATURAL GRIP'S ONLY BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR A YEAR NOW,
AND WE HAVE $178,000 IN SALES.
GOOD FOR YOU.
THAT'S GOOD.
WHAT WAS YOUR
FULL-TIME JOB?
WHAT DID YOU DO
BEFORE YOU DID THIS?
OKAY, SO, MY FULL-TIME JOB
IS I'M ACTIVE-DUTY ARMY.
WOW.
HOW DID YOU EVEN GET HERE?
John: YEAH.
WHAT -- WHY THIS?
WHY DID YOU CREATE IT?
I STARTED CrossFit IN 2012,
AND I STARTED RIPPING MY HANDS,
AND I WAS SO DEVASTATED,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU RIP YOUR HANDS,
YOU'RE OUT OF THE GYM
FOR AT LEAST THREE OR FOUR DAYS
WHILE YOU HEAL.
SO I TRIED TO FIND SOMETHING
TO FIX THE PROBLEM,
AND NONE OF IT WAS WORKING.
MY HUSBAND GOT SICK
OF HEARING ME COMPLAIN ABOUT IT,
AND HE SAID, "I THINK
I CAN MAKE YOU SOMETHING
THAT'LL FIX THIS PROBLEM."
AND WE DIDN'T KNOW IT THEN,
BUT THE NATURAL GRIP WAS BORN.
I'M CURIOUS. WHY DON'T
THE OTHER PRODUCTS WORK?
'CAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
OF OTHER PRODUCTS.
SO THE OTHER GRIPS ARE LEATHER,
SO THEY'RE BULKY.
THEY'RE NYLON OR CLOTH,
SO THEY'RE SLICK.
SO WHAT'S PROPRIETARY
ABOUT YOURS IS THE MATERIAL.
NO. WHAT'S PROPRIETARY
ABOUT MINE,
AND WHAT I HAVE
A PATENT PENDING ON,
IS THE METHOD
OF A REUSABLE TAPE GRIP
BASED OFF OF RING-FINGER SIZE.
WHAT -- WHAT MATERIAL
IS THIS?
THAT IS 100% COTTON
ADHESIVE MATERIAL.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU SELLING
THESE UNITS FOR?
SO, RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ON A DISTRIBUTOR MODEL.
WE SELL TO DISTRIBUTORS
FOR $10 A UNIT,
AND THEN THEY RESELL IT
FOR $17 A UNIT.
HOW MANY UNITS
HAVE YOU SOLD NOW?
I'VE SOLD 13,000 UNITS.
WHAT DOES IT COST
FOR EACH PACKAGE?
SO, EACH UNIT COSTS ME
$4.43 TO MAKE.
$4 OF THE $4.43 IS LABOR.
ARE YOU MAKING THEM?
LIKE --
I FOUND SUBCONTRACTORS --
STAY-AT-HOME MOM,
HIGH-SCHOOL KIDS, RETIREES,
PEOPLE THAT NEEDED WORK.
AND I SAID, "I WILL TRAIN YOU.
TAKE MY MATERIAL.
AND I WILL PAY YOU BY THE PIECE
WHEN YOU DROP OFF."
I OWN THE NUMBER-ONE CrossFit
IN THE WORLD,
WHICH IS ON FIFTH AVE.
IS YOUR MARKET PURELY
JUST CrossFitters?
IS THERE A MARKET
OUTSIDE OF CrossFit?
ABSOLUTELY. WHY?
POWER LIFTERS, OLYMPIC LIFTERS.
I HAVE MOTORCROSS GUYS
THAT ARE BUYING THIS PRODUCT.
YEAH, I COULD SEE THAT.
Greiner: I THINK YOU'RE AMAZING,
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE.
YOU CAME IN,
YOU KNOW YOUR STUFF,
YOU HAVE A GREAT
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT.
FOR ME, THOUGH,
I HAVE TO BE PASSIONATE
ABOUT EVERYTHING I INVEST IN,
AND I'M NOT FEELING THE PASSION
ON THIS ONE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Herjavec: SO,
ASHLEY, YOUR PROBLEM IS
YOU NEED THE MONEY TO BUILD
INVENTORY TO FILL DEMAND.
TO MANUFACTURE THIS
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND TO --
TO GET MORE OF THEM
TO BUILD INVENTORY
SO WHEN I GET THE ORDERS FROM
MY DISTRIBUTORS FOR THOUSANDS,
I CAN FILL IT.
RIGHT NOW, THEY WAIT.
WHAT'S THE TURN-- WHAT'S
THE TURN-AROUND TIME NOW?
WITH THE CURRENT 6-MAN STAFF,
I CAN DO 3,000 UNITS A MONTH.
WOW. THAT'S A MAJOR CONSTRAINT
TO YOUR BUSINESS.
I ADMIT YOU HAVE SALES.
SOMETHING'S WORKING.
BUT FOR ME,
I CAN'T GET EXCITED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE OF HOW VERTICAL NICHE-Y
IT IS. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
ASHLEY, TWO YEARS FROM NOW,
THREE YEARS FROM NOW,
HOW BIG IS THIS,
WHAT ARE THE SALES,
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
I -- I BELIEVE
IF WE CAN KEEP UP WITH DEMAND,
WE WILL GROSS $400,000
IN -- IN SALES THIS YEAR.
BUT IN 2015, IF WE CAN KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND,
WE WILL -- WE WILL HIT
$1 MILLION IN SALES.
WHY? BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY
I'M TARGETING TO RIGHT NOW
IS GROWING.
I HAVE A PRODUCT THAT WEARS OUT
THAT YOU'RE GONNA NEED IT AGAIN,
THEN I CAN EXPAND
OUTSIDE OF CrossFit.
I DON'T THINK YOU WANT
TO EXPAND OUTSIDE OF CrossFit.
THAT'S NOT
THE OPPORTUNITY.
THE OPPORTUNITY IS ADDING
ADDITIONAL PRODUCTS
THAT LEVERAGE
YOUR CREDIBILITY
AND THE TRUST THAT
YOU'VE DEVELOPED.
HE'S SO WRONG.
I-I'M RIGHT.
TRUST ME.
I BUILT IT FOR THE CrossFit
COMMUNITY, BUT THE FACT
THAT IT COULD HELP OTHER PEOPLE
OUT THERE, I'M OPEN TO THAT.
I'M SOLVING A PROBLEM,
SO IF SOMEONE ELSE
IS RIPPING THEIR HANDS,
LET'S SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
RIGHT NOW, THOUGH, LET'S DEAL --
HOO-RAH!
LET'S DEAL WITH THIS --
RIGHT.
THIS THAT WE HAVE GOING ON.
YOU ARE ONE
MOTIVATED COWBOY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE NOT WASTING YOUR TIME
IN "SHARK TANK,"
I MUST SAY THAT.
I MEAN, THE FACT THAT
I WAS ABLE TO GET HERE
IN THIS SMALL AMOUNT OF TIME.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
ALL RIGHT, SOMEBODY GIVE
THIS WOMAN $100,000
AND GET HER OUT OF HERE.
YEAH.
WHO'S IN AGAIN?
ME, YOU, AND ROBERT.
I'M NOT GONNA FALL
FOR YOUR CRAP THIS TIME.
Herjavec: YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DO THIS EVERY TIME.
I GET IMPATIENT,
AND THEN CUBAN COMES IN
IN THE 11th HOUR,
SO I'M JUST GONNA SIT HERE
AND WAIT.
O'Leary:
WHY DON'T YOU DECLARE, MARK?
SHOWDOWN AT O.K. CORRAL.
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT,
AND IT SEEMS MARK, DAYMOND,
AND ROBERT ARE AT A STANDOFF.
ROBERT,
YOU GONNA MAKE AN OFFER?
JUST --
JUST THINKING.
WHAT'S MARK'S FAMOUS LINE?
"I'M JUST THINKING."
WELL, MAKE AN OFFER.
I'M DYING OF OLD AGE.
Cuban: I DON'T CARE
WHAT THESE GUYS DO.
BUT I LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
OBVIOUSLY,
YOU DESERVE SO MUCH CREDIT.
I SEE THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO KEEP UP.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT WHAT I DIDN'T SEE WAS
WHAT'S NEXT, RIGHT?
WHAT I WAS HOPING
TO HEAR WAS,
"AFTER THIS PRODUCT,
THEN THERE'S THE TAPE.
"AFTER THE TAPE, THERE'S THIS,
THEN THAT AND THIS
SO THAT WE CAN GROW IT
INTO SOMETHING ENORMOUS."
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, ASHLEY.
SO, WE ALL KNOW
I'M THE SPORTY SHARK.
YOU HAVE
TREMENDOUS CREDIBILITY,
AND YOU'RE A GREAT OPERATOR.
EVERY BUSINESS I'VE INVESTED IN
ON "SHARK TANK"
THAT HAD A GREAT OPERATOR
HAS SUCCEEDED.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 30%.
HEY, THERE!
AND I AM WITH YOU 100%
ON THE STRATEGY.
Greiner: HOO-HA.
HOO-RAH.
LET'S GO.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I GOT IT.
I THINK YOU --
I THINK YOU NEED MORE
THAN JUST THE MONEY.
I KNOW ROBERT HAS
A COUPLE CONNECTIONS,
BUT OBVIOUSLY
I'M IN THIS SPACE.
SO I'M WILLING TO GO
IN $100,000 FOR...40%.
OOH.
AND I'M A PARTNER
WITH THE ONLY PERSON
THAT CAN PUT "REEBOK"
ON THE BOXES.
IT'S NOT A REEBOK SALE.
I MEAN,
WHAT YOU'RE DOING TODAY
IS WHAT YOU NEED
TO KEEP DOING.
AND I'M -- I'M VERY THANKFUL
FOR BOTH OF THOSE OFFERS.
I HAVE A MANUFACTURING ISSUE.
I DON'T NEED MORE FANCY PEOPLE
WEARING MY GRIPS
'CAUSE I CAN'T MAKE THEM
FAST ENOUGH
TO SELL TO THE STAY-AT-HOME MOM
RIGHT NOW.
I'VE BEEN MANUFACTURING
SINCE THE DAY I WAS BORN.
I ACTUALLY TOOK MY UMBILICAL
CORD AND MADE IT INTO A BELT.
OKAY.
SO DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
Greiner: UNH-UNH.
I CAN HELP YOU
WITH THE MANUFACTURING.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT.
I'M GONNA SWEETEN MY OFFER.
I'M ACTUALLY GONNA
GIVE YOU MORE.
$125,000 FOR 25%.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $100,000
FOR 33%.
I KNOW THE WHOLE COMMUNITY.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
AND I KNOW
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
FOR THE MANUFACTURING SIDE
BEFORE WE GO ANYPLACE ELSE.
AND I'M DYING OF OLD AGE.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT DO YOU FEEL
IN YOUR GUT?
UM, I FEEL IN MY GUT
THAT DAYMOND,
YOU'RE VERY WELL-CONNECTED
AND YOU KNOW THE INDUSTRY,
BUT I'VE BEEN LIVING
THE GRIND FOR A YEAR,
AND HARD WORK, ENERGY,
AND EFFORT --
I ONLY GET LESS THAN FOUR HOURS
OF SLEEP, HONESTLY.
AND I FEEL LIKE ROBERT
CAN HELP ME GET THERE,
AND I WANT TO DO A DEAL
WITH YOU.
LET'S DO IT.
Cuban: CONGRATULATIONS.
O'Leary: OH.
Greiner: CONGRATULATIONS,
DANIELLE.
DIDN'T SEE THAT COMING.
THAT IS A BIG MISTAKE.
Greiner: CONGRATS.
THANK YOU.
[ GIGGLES ]
LOVE IT.
YOU KNOW,
IF THAT DIDN'T WORK,
I WAS GONNA CHALLENGE YOU
TO A CHIN-UP CONTEST,
AND THEN JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT.
SHE JUST PARTNERED UP
WITH A CYBER-THEFT GUY.
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, NO.
SHE PARTNERED UP
WITH A SPORTY SHARK.
I'M SO HAPPY FOR YOU!
[ LAUGHS ]
Drake: THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
MY HUSBAND AND OUR 3-YEAR-OLD,
IT'S GONNA BE LIFE-CHANGING,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S JUST --
I'M JUST SO THANKFUL FOR IT.
AND, LIKE, HARD WORK,
IT PAYS OFF.
[ WOMAN SHOUTS ]
[ ALL SHOUT ]
WE'RE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
YES, "SHARK TANK"
IN THE NATION'S CAPITAL.
John: HERE THEY COME.
PAIGE, ASHLEY, ROB,
WELCOME TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WELCOME!
ALSO JOINING US TODAY
ARE ACTIVE-DUTY
AND VETERAN ENTREPRENEURS
WHO MADE DEALS WITH US
ON "SHARK TANK."
THIS IS BIG TIME
FOR ALL OF US.
WE'RE AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY
BECAUSE "SHARK TANK"
HAS BEEN INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE
IN A CHAMPIONS
OF CHANGE EVENT
THAT CELEBRATES
VETERAN ENTREPRENEURS.
I AM SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
WHY DON'T WE GO CHECK IT OUT,
ALL RIGHT?
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO DO IT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
VALERIE JARRETT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID
AGAIN AND AGAIN,
"WE MUST SUPPORT OUR VETERANS
"AS THEY TRANSITION
FROM PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY
TO LEADING OUR COUNTRY
IN SO MANY WAYS."
O'Leary: WE'RE HERE TO HONOR
VETERAN ENTREPRENEURS
AND ALSO PROVIDE
OUR OWN ADVICE
TO THOSE THAT ASPIRE
TO BECOME ENTREPRENEURS.
O'Leary: MANY OF THE ATTRIBUTES
THAT YOU'RE TRAINED AT
ARE VERY USEFUL IN BUSINESS.
LEADERSHIP IS ONE OF OUR BEST
TRAITS THAT WE BRING AS VETS.
I LOOK FOR DESIRE, DRIVE, HONOR,
AND THE ABILITY
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
FOR US, IT WAS
ALL ABOUT JUST FINDING
WHAT WE WERE PASSIONATE ABOUT
AND RUNNING WITH IT.
DON'T START A BUSINESS.
FIND A PROBLEM,
SOLVE A PROBLEM.
THE BUSINESS COMES SECOND.
THESE VETS ALREADY
HAVE THE TOOLS
AND THE DETERMINATION
TO SUCCEED.
ALL THEY NEED
IS A LITTLE GUIDANCE,
BUT THEY KNOW HOW TO WIN.
AS THESE GUYS COME BACK
FROM THE BATTLEFIELDS,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHOW THEM
THAT THEIR UNIQUE SKILL SET
CAN BE APPLIED
TO STARTING THEIR OWN BUSINESS.
SOMETIMES, THEY JUST NEED
TO BE SHOWN THE PATH.
Man: ONE MORE ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR THIS TEAM UP HERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ INDISTINCT CONVERSATIONS ]
O'Leary: THIS IS THE EPICENTER
OF FREEDOM IN THE WORLD,
OF CAPITALISM,
OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
WITH "SHARK TANK"
AND THE WHITE HOUSE
WORKING TOGETHER,
WE CAN INSPIRE
A WHOLE NEW GENERATION
OF ENTREPRENEURS TO MAKE
OUR ECONOMY GROW EVEN FASTER.
OUR VETERANS ARE SOME
OF THE MOST TALENTED
AND CREATIVE LEADERS
IN OUR COUNTRY,
AND IT'S NO SURPRISE
THAT MANY OF THEM
GO ON TO LEAD BUSINESSES
OF THEIR OWN
WHEN THEIR SERVICE ENDS.
SO MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE THRILLED TO CELEBRATE
VETERANS SMALL BUSINESS WEEK
WITH ALL OF YOU AT "SHARK TANK."
NOW, THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY,
WE'RE CONNECTING VETERANS
WITH WORKSHOPS, RESOURCES,
AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
TO HELP THEM LAUNCH
AND GROW THEIR BUSINESSES
BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT JOINING FORCES
WITH VETERAN ENTREPRENEURS
ISN'T JUST GOOD
FOR THEIR BOTTOM LINE,
IT'S GOOD
FOR OUR ENTIRE COUNTRY.
SO TO ALL OF OUR VETERANS
ON "SHARK TANK"
AND ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
WE WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT WE'VE GOT YOUR BACK.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A BUSINESS
UTILIZING MAN'S BEST FRIEND.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S LORI MORRELL
AND I'M FROM COLUMBUS, OHIO.
I'M THE OWNER
OF PRIORITY 1 CANINE.
I'M HERE SEEKING $75,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 15% OF MY COMPANY.
TRAINING A DOG TAKES A LOT
OF TIME AND PATIENCE,
BUT IT ALL PAYS OFF IN THE END
WHEN YOUR BEST FRIEND IS THERE
FOR WHEN YOU NEED HIM THE MOST.
HEY, LADY!
[ DOG BARKING ]
LIKE MAYBE WHEN
YOUR SAFETY'S IN DANGER.
DO YOU HAVE ANY MONEY?
GIVE ME YOUR MONEY!
I KNOW YOU HAVE MONEY.
GIVE YOUR MONEY!
Herjavec: WHOA!
WHOA!
OH, MY GOD!
[ SPEAKS DUTCH ]
WOW!
[ DOG BARKS ]
I WANT THAT DOG.
[ LORI SPEAKS DUTCH ]
Wade: HEY, SHARKS.
HOW YOU DOING?
MY NAME IS WADE MORRELL.
I'M LORI'S HUSBAND
AND THE CO-OWNER
OF PRIORITY 1 CANINE.
WE TRAIN AND SELL THE WORLD'S
FINEST CANINE BODYGUARDS
FOR PERSONAL, HOME,
AND FAMILY SECURITY.
Lori: YOU'RE PROBABLY
ASKING YOURSELF
"WHO NEEDS A PERSONAL
CANINE BODYGUARD?"
THE ANSWER MIGHT BE YOU.
THE AVERAGE POLICE
RESPONSE TIME IN AMERICA
IS 7 TO 10 MINUTES.
THAT'S 7 TO 10 MINUTES
THAT YOU JUST CAN'T WASTE.
WE HAND-SELECT AND TRAIN
EACH CANINE
TO MEET OUR CLIENT'S INDIVIDUAL
PERSONAL SECURITY NEEDS,
WHETHER IT BE PROTECTION
FROM CARJACKING,
PERIMETER SECURITY,
OR PERSONAL SECURITY
WHILE AT HOME OR AWAY.
SO, SHARKS, WHICH ONE OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TEAM UP WITH US
AND BECOME A PART
OF THE MOST ELITE
CANINE SECURITY COMPANY
IN THE COUNTRY?
[ DOG GROWLS ]
OH, MY GOD.
[ LORI SPEAKS DUTCH ]
Herjavec:
LORI, THAT WAS SO COOL.
BUT FOR ME
TO REALLY GET IT,
I NEED TO SEE
THE DEMO AGAIN.
CAN KEVIN PUT ON
THE CLOTHES?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT LANGUAGE ARE YOU
SPEAKING TO THE DOG?
Lori: DUTCH.
Herjavec: IS SHE FRIENDLY,
OR IS SHE SO TIGHTLY WOUND
THAT SHE CAN'T BE
A FAMILY PET?
Lori: OH, NO.
ALL OF OUR CANINES
ARE FAMILY PETS.
THEY LIVE IN THE HOME
WITH -- WITH THE FAMILY.
WHY IS SHE STARING AT HIM
SO INTENTLY?
SHE'S IN PROTECTION MODE
RIGHT NOW.
FOR YOU?
YES.
THAT'S VERY INTERESTING.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXCUSE HER
SO WE GET BACK TO THE --
THE NITTY-GRITTY OF THINGS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
ROXY [SPEAKS DUTCH]
WOW, THAT'S INTENSE.
Herjavec:
THAT IS SO IMPRESSIVE.
THAT'S A VERY
TIGHTLY WOUND ANIMAL.
ALMOST A -- IT IS A WEAPON.
CAN YOU DO THE SAME THING
WITH, LET'S SAY, A CHIHUAHUA?
[ LAUGHTER ]
IS IT ONLY GERMAN SHEPHERDS?
Wade: NO, WE --
WE SPECIFICALLY USE
ABOUT THREE OR FOUR DIFFERENT
PREDOMINANT BREEDS --
THE BELGIAN SHEPHERD,
LIKE YOU SAW TODAY,
OR THE BELGIAN MALINOIS,
THE DUTCH SHEPHERD,
AND THE ALSO
THE GERMAN SHEPHERD.
WE ACTUALLY
HAND-SELECT THE DOG
THAT'S GONNA MEET
YOUR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS.
WE COME TO YOUR HOUSE,
WE SEE HOW YOU LIVE.
DO YOU HAVE KIDS?
WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO USE THE DOG FOR?
WALK ME THROUGH NUMBERS.
I NEED A DOG.
WHAT DO YOU CHARGE ME?
WE HAVE THREE DIFFERENT
TRAINING PACKAGES.
WE HAVE A LEVEL ONE,
WHICH IS A $20,000
TRAINING PACKAGE --
DOES THAT INCLUDE THE DOG?
THAT INCLUDES THE DOG,
YES.
...A LEVEL TWO,
WHICH IS A $30,000,
AND THEN A LEVEL THREE,
WHICH IS A $40,000 PACKAGE.
AND WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE?
IT GOES ON THE --
THE AMOUNT OF TRAINING
THAT'S PUT INTO THE DOG.
SO THE BASIC LEVEL ONE DOG
WOULD BE A DOG THAT,
IF SOMEONE WAS TO COME
TO YOUR HOUSE,
RING THE DOORBELL,
THE DOG WOULD GO TO
THE FRONT DOOR AND BARK
AND LOOK
LIKE A THREATENING DOG.
LEVEL TWO, WE START GOING INTO
HIGHER LEVELS OF TRAINING --
IF YOU'RE A JOGGER
OR IF YOU WANT
A CARJACKING SCENARIO
PLACED INTO THE DOG.
ONCE YOU GET INTO
A LEVEL THREE DOG,
YOU GET THE FULL SHEBANG.
YOU KNOW, I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT YOUR BACKGROUND,
BECAUSE YOU FEEL TO ME
LIKE MAYBE ARMY,
S.E.A.L.s, SOMETHING.
YES, MA'AM.
I'M A FORMER
UNITED STATES MARINE.
I'VE BEEN A POLICE OFFICER
FOR THE LAST 14 YEARS.
S.W.A.T. TEAMS,
POLICE DEPARTMENTS
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES
REQUEST ME TO TEACH THEM
HOW TO DO THIS
WITH THEIR DOGS.
AND, LORI,
ARE YOU INVOLVED, TOO?
YES, I ACTUALLY CAME
FROM CORPORATE AMERICA.
BUT I CAME HOME ONE DAY,
AND I TOLD WADE --
I SAID, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING WITH ANIMALS."
AND HE GOES, "GO FOR IT."
HOW MANY DOGS DID YOU SELL, OR
WHATEVER THE TERM IS, LAST YEAR?
Cuban: WERE PLACED LAST YEAR?
HOW MANY DOGS
HAVE YOU PLACED SO FAR?
WE'VE TRAINED AND PLACED
11 DOGS SO FAR.
THIS YEAR?
Wade: IN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF.
Lori: IN THE LAST
YES, SIR.
WHAT ARE YOUR REVENUES?
IT'S ABOUT $150,000,
AND WE MADE ABOUT $75,000.
THE INHERENT PROBLEM HERE
IS SCALABILITY.
HOW DO I TURN THIS INTO A
MULTI-MILLION-DOLLAR BUSINESS?
I THINK THAT'S
VERY, VERY CHALLENGING.
THIS IS SUCH
A PERFECT THING FOR YOU.
NO, IT'S --
LIKE, DOG
THAT RIPS SOMEONE'S --
NO, I LIKE THAT PART
BECAUSE I COULD JUST SAY --
YOU KNOW, CUBAN'S COMPETING
WITH ME ON A DEAL,
I JUST SEND THE DOG OVER.
YEAH.
Greiner: MM-HMM.
THAT'S IT.
Wade: I DON'T MEAN
TO INTERRUPT YOU, SIR,
BUT IF WE DO 20 DOGS A YEAR
AT $40,000,
THAT'S $800,000 A YEAR.
I'VE NEVER BEEN A RICH PERSON.
I PROBABLY NEVER WILL BE.
THAT'S PLENTY OF MONEY
TO ME.
THAT IS A FANTASTIC LIVING
FOR YOU.
BUT EVEN AT $800,000,
AS AN INVESTABLE BUSINESS,
IT'S VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
TO SCALE THAT KIND OF THING.
IF WE 9 NINE DOGS A MONTH,
72 DOGS A YEAR...
YEAH, BUT, LORI, HERE'S --
...WE'RE LOOKING
AT $2.4 MILLION.
YEAH, HERE'S THE CHALLENGE.
IT'S YOU.
IT'S SUCH A HANDS-ON
TYPE OF BUSINESS.
A WEAPON LIKE THAT
IS HIGHLY, HIGHLY TRAINED
THAT NEEDS PEOPLE LIKE YOU
TO CONSTANTLY RETUNE IT.
AND WE DO THAT.
YEAH, ACTUALLY, THAT'S --
BUT AGAIN, IT GOES TO MY POINT.
IT'S YOU.
I DON'T THINK YOU FOUND
AN INVESTOR IN ME TODAY.
PERHAPS A CUSTOMER.
I'M OUT.
IF YOU GOT THIS UP
TO $1 MILLION IN SALES,
WHICH I THINK YOU COULD...
YEAH.
...IT'S NOT REALLY INTERESTING
FOR AN INVESTOR.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO PUT OUR CAPITAL
IN MAY DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
WE LOOK FOR
UNLIMITED SCALABILITY.
I-I DON'T SEE IT HERE.
I'M OUT.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR YOU
SAY THAT, KEVIN.
WE REALLY NEED A PARTNER
TO HELP US HERE.
WE'RE NOT -- I JUST --
I JUST BEEN A MARINE,
A POLICE OFFICER, AND A DOG
TRAINER MY WHOLE LIFE.
I NEED SOMEBODY
WITH THAT LITTLE BIT
OF EXTRA BUSINESS SENSE
TO HELP US TAKE THIS -- THIS
BUSINESS TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
MAYBE IT WON'T BE A $5 MILLION
OR $10 MILLION COMPANY.
MAYBE WE DO $2 MILLION.
BUT HOW --
BUT YOU MAY GET TO $2 MILLION
ON YOUR OWN,
AND THAT'S A GREAT LIVING
FOR YOU GUYS.
Cuban: THERE'S DIFFERENT TYPES
OF INVESTMENTS.
FOR SOME, THEY JUST NEED
THE CASH, RIGHT?
AND FOR OTHERS,
THEY WANT CONTACTS
AND EXPERTISE AND MENTORING.
CONTACTS, EXPERTISE,
AND MENTORING IS EXPENSIVE
FROM OUR END,
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
GETTING TO $2 MILLION
RELATIVE TO OUR TIME,
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S GONNA TAKE MORE TIME
THAN THE REWARD WOULD BE,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, SIR.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
Greiner:
YOU GUYS ARE REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
I COULD TELL THE MINUTE
YOU WALKED IN
YOU HAD A MILITARY BACKGROUND.
YOU CALLED EVERYBODY "SIR"
CONSTANTLY, KEPT YOUR COOL.
I THINK TO THE POINT
THE OTHER SHARKS ARE SAYING
IS YOU DON'T HAVE TO SCALE IT
REALLY HUGE.
IF YOU MAKE A GREAT LIVING
OFF IT, THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED,
AND I DON'T SAY THAT VERY OFTEN.
IT WOULD BE HARD FOR US
TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY FROM IT
OR TO BE ABLE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO YOU.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
BUT I SEE YOU AS WINNERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MA'AM.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
DAYMOND, Y-YOU'RE
A HUGE DOG LOVER.
John: I AM.
AND IF YOU CAN COME OVER AND
TEACH LITTLE BLAKE AND SPARTAN
TO PEE ON THE WEE-WEE PAD,
I WOULD SAY SO MANY THINGS.
HIS CHIHUAHUA.
DONE.
I'M NOT SURE
THOSE ARE DOGS.
THEY ARE.
THEY'RE LITTLE HOT DOGS.
SO I'M A PRODUCT GUY,
AND, YOU KNOW,
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTION,
LICENSING.
I DON'T THINK I CAN HELP YOU
IN THAT SERVICE.
YOU CAN. YOU CAN.
YOU CAN ABSOLUTELY HELP US.
BUT I CAN'T TURN YOUR BUSINESS
INTO A BIG BUSINESS
WHERE I CAN GET ACTUALLY
A RETURN ON MY CAPITAL.
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THIS HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTELY
AWESOME EXPERIENCE FOR US.
CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR SUCCESS.
YOU GUYS HAVE
A GREAT BUSINESS.
GREAT JOB.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
I WANT THE KILLER CHIHUAHUA
TO TAKE HIM OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
Cuban: CONGRATS, GUYS.
Wade: THANKS.
APPRECIATE IT.
THAT IS SO YOUR BUSINESS.
O'Leary: ARE YOU KIDDING?
A DOG THAT WILL CUT
YOUR THROAT OPEN.
IF THAT WAS AROUND
WITH YOUNG KIDS
AND IT JUST HAD A BAD HAIR DAY,
IT WOULD EAT SOMEBODY'S HEAD.
[ LAUGHS ]
Wade:
OUR GOAL WAS TO COME IN
AND SHOW THE SHARKS
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF BUSINESS,
KIND OF BLOW
THEIR DOORS OFF.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY,
THEY DIDN'T SEE IT THAT WAY.
LITTLE BUMMED.
AND DISAPPOINTED.
YEAH.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
WITH A BETTER VERSION
OF THE MODERN MAN BAG.
HI.
MY NAME'S AARON TWEEDIE,
AND I'M FROM FRONT ROYAL,
VIRGINIA.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING $200,000
FOR A 29% STAKE IN MY COMPANY,
MAN-PACK.
THE MAN-PACK IS A SLING-STYLE
VERTICAL MESSENGER BAG
DESIGNED BY GUYS, FOR GUYS.
YOU KNOW, 40 YEARS AGO,
MEN CARRIED NOTHING MORE
THAN A MONEY CLIP,
BUT TIMES HAVE CHANGED.
ON AVERAGE, GUYS NOW CARRY
4.5 POUNDS OF STUFF,
THINGS LIKE KEYS, CELLPHONES,
TABLETS, ENERGY DRINKS.
POINT IS, GUYS NEED
TO CARRY STUFF,
AND WE HAVE VERY FEW OPTIONS.
WE HAVE THE BACKPACK,
THE BRIEFCASE,
THE TRADITIONAL MESSENGER BAG,
AND I'M SURE ALL OF YOU
REMEMBER THE FANNY PACK.
I HAVE DESIGNED
A SUPERIOR PRODUCT
THAT I CALL URBAN TACTICAL.
YOU CAN WEAR THIS THING
THREE DIFFERENT WAYS.
FIRST WAY IS BANDOLEER STYLE.
IF YOU NEED
TO TAKE IT OFF QUICKLY,
IT HAS A QUICK-RELEASE CLASP.
A CHEST-MOUNTED UTILITY POCKET
FOR YOUR CELLPHONE
WITH A MAGNETIC BUTTON CLOSURE.
LINE IT UP, LOCKS ITSELF SHUT.
THREE ROWS OF MOLLE
FOR TACTICAL GEAR,
AND A COLLAPSIBLE
BEVERAGE HOLDER.
WHEN YOU NEED IT, IT'S THERE.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHEN YOU DON'T, IT FOLDS UP --
NOT THE COLLAPSIBLE
BEVERAGE HOLDER!
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
...IT FOLDS UP
AND OUT OF THE WAY.
TO GET INTO IT, YOU DON'T NEED
TO TAKE IT OFF.
JUST SPIN IT AROUND
AND OPEN IT UP.
PLUS, YOU HAVE AUXILIARY POCKETS
FOR THINGS LIKE YOUR WALLET,
LOOSE POCKET CHANGE, KEYS.
NOW, IF YOU'RE SOMEPLACE
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA TAKE IT
ON AND OFF FREQUENTLY,
YOU CAN THROW IT
OVER ONE SHOULDER.
NOTICE HOW THE WEIGHT STILL
HANGS OVER YOUR LOWER BACK
DUE TO THE ERGONOMIC DESIGN
OF THE STRAP.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND IF YOU'RE IN THE CITY
ON THE METRO,
YOU CAN WEAR IT REVERSE,
KEEP YOUR POSSESSIONS
IN FRONT OF YOU
AND SAFE FROM PICKPOCKETS.
THE MISSION STATEMENT
OF MAN-PACK
IS TO MAKE MEN MORE PREPARED,
BECAUSE A PREPARED MAN
IS A BETTER MAN.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT,
WE CAN TURN THE "MAN-BAG MARKET"
INTO THE MAN-PACK MARKET.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT,
AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
Herjavec: AARON,
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
GET IT, BABY.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
ARE YOU --
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
ARE YOU A DESIGNER?
UH, NO.
I BUILT MY FIRST HOUSE
WHEN I WAS 19,
AND I WAS IN FORT BENNING,
GEORGIA, WHEN I WAS 17.
WERE YOU IN THE ARMY?
I WAS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU FIRST
WALKED IN, I LOOKED AT IT
AND I THOUGHT, "OH,
ANOTHER KNAPSACK FOR GUYS.
WHATEVER."
BUT YOU DEFINITELY WOWED ME
WITH THE UTILITY OF IT.
CAN WE SEE THEM?
CAN YOU HAND -- CAN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT ONE?
SURE. YES.
FOR YOU.
THANK YOU.
HERE YOU GO.
O'Leary:
GIVE ME THE BLACK ONE.
THANKS.
YOU GET THE XL.
YEAH.
Herjavec:
YEAH, HE NEEDS THE XL.
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: THANK YOU, SIR.
APPRECIATE IT.
HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY OF THESE?
Tweedie: I HAVE. I HAVE.
Greiner: WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
John: WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
OKAY.
SO, LAST YEAR, $76,000.
THIS YEAR, WE'RE AT $65,000,
YEAR TO DATE.
Greiner: IS THAT ONLINE?
IT IS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS YEAR?
$145,000.
WHAT DO YOU
SELL THEM FOR?
$59.95.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE THEM FOR?
Greiner:
THEY COST, RIGHT NOW,
$22.05 A PIECE.
SO THIS PRODUCT
REQUIRES AN EXPLANATION,
'CAUSE IT'S HARD
TO DIFFERENTIATE IT
AGAINST ANYTHING ELSE.
THAT'S TRUE.
YOU HAVE TO EDUCATE THE CONSUMER
BECAUSE THIS IS
AN EMERGING MARKET.
BAGS ARE EMERGING MARKET?
THIS IS THE MILLENNIAL
VERSION OF THE MURSE.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT IT'S NOT -- RIGHT.
IT'S NOT A PURSE,
IT'S NOT A BACKPACK.
IT'S A MURSE!
YOU KNOW WHAT --
IT'S A MAN -- IT'S A MAN-PACK.
Herjavec: BUT, AARON,
HERE'S THE CONCERN.
SURE. OKAY.
WHEN I WAS EUROPE LAST SUMMER
WITH MY FAMILY...
RIGHT.
...I HAD A SIMILAR BAG,
AND I WASN'T ASHAMED
TO WEAR IT IN PUBLIC
BECAUSE EVERY OTHER GUY
IN EUROPE HAD ONE.
EXACTLY.
WHEN I CAME BACK HERE,
I PUT THE SAME THING ON,
I DIDN'T MAKE IT ONE BLOCK
DOWN THE STREET,
EVERYBODY WAS LAUGHING AT ME.
YOU KNOW, IT --
Greiner:
BUT THAT'S NOT A MURSE.
ROBERT, I DON'T THINK THEY
WERE LAUGHING AT YOU FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF THINGS.
ONE, IT'S NOT A MURSE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE GUYS
THAT I SELL TO,
THE SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
AND MILITARY PERSONNEL
AND LAW-ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL --
I NEVER LAUGH AT SOMEBODY
WITH A GUN.
RIGHT. EXACTLY.
WELL, LET'S GO
TO THE REAL NUMBERS.
HOW MANY DID YOU SELL
LAST MONTH, ONLINE ONLY?
PROBABLY LIKE 40.
THAT'S --
YOU KNOW, I MEAN, IT'S NOT GOOD.
BUT I STARTED THIS WITH $5,000.
I'VE BEEN DOING A LOT
WITH NEXT TO NOTHING.
WHY DO YOU THINK
THE COMPANY'S WORTH $700,000?
OKAY, UM, $50,000 FOR
THE DESIGN PATENT, WHICH WE --
BUT WHAT DID YOU GET
THE DESIGN PATENT FOR?
FOR THIS MODEL.
LIKE, WHAT --
A BAG WITH A STRAP
THAT HAS SO MANY POCKETS?
Greiner: JUST THE LOOK OF IT.
IT'S JUST THE LOOK OF IT.
WHAT ELSE ARE YOU ADDING
TO THE VALUE?
A MULTIPLE OF SALES
FOR TWO YEARS
BEING THE $145,000 PROJECTION.
$18,000 INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY,
THAT BEING THE BANK OF YOUTUBE
COMMERCIALS THAT I'VE CREATED.
THEY'RE REALLY FUNNY.
YOU SHOULD CHECK THEM OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU'RE PUTTING A HARD VALUE
ON THOSE?
VALUE IS A MATTER
OF PERCEPTION.
YES, IT IS.
AND WE'RE ON --
IF WE'RE ON AN ISLAND
AND YOU HAVE A BAR OF GOLD I
HAVE A CHEESEBURGER, WHO'S RICH?
I'LL TAKE THE GOLD.
OKAY.
I'M GONNA GET IN THE PLANE
AND LEAVE THE ISLAND.
[ LAUGHS ]
John: LET'S GO -- ROBERT,
HOLD ON. ARE WE DONE?
ARE WE DONE
WITH ALL THE NUMBERS?
I WAS JUST --
N-NO.
UM, OKAY,
AND $200,000 IN GOOD WILL.
AND $200,000
IN GOOD WILL.
[ LAUGHS ]
O'Leary:
IF I GAVE YOU $200,000,
I'D HAVE TO OWN
ABOUT 260% OF THE COMPANY.
ABOUT THAT.
'CAUSE YOU HAVE
VERY SMALL SALES.
THAT'S THE REASON I'M OUT.
I'M JUST A DISCIPLINED
FINANCIAL INVESTOR.
I UNDERSTAND.
Cuban: I KIND OF AGREE
WITH KEVIN.
I THINK THIS -- THIS IS
A HARD BUSINESS TO INVEST IN.
I THINK YOU'RE A HUSTLER,
AND YOU'RE A GREAT SALESPERSON.
I JUST THINK IT'S HARD
FOR YOU TO SCALE,
WHICH MAKES IT HARD
TO INVEST IN.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
WE SEE MANY PEOPLE
WITH, UM, GOOD SALES, BAD SALES,
AND THEN WE NORMALLY BET
ON THE PERSON.
AND THANK YOU
FOR SERVING OUR COUNTRY.
THANK YOU.
WE ALSO LOOK
FOR SMALL INDICATIONS
ON HOW GOOD
THIS PARTNER WOULD BE.
YOUR "I'M GONNA CHARGE
$20,000 FOR THE --"
YOUR VIDEOS, THAT YOU
MAY HAVE MADE AT HOME --
IT INDICATED
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
A SENSE OF FINANCIAL
INTELLIGENCE
WHEN IT COMES
TO WHAT PARTNERS NEED
IN OPERATING THIS BUSINESS.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
AS IMPRESSED AS I AM WITH YOU,
TO ME, IT LOOKS LIKE
A MESSENGER BAG.
SO YOU'VE GOT TO GO,
AND YOU GOT TO RUN
REAL FAST, BABY.
YOU GOT TO GET OUT THERE.
BUT THAT'S A JOURNEY
FOR YOU.
AND YOU'RE A TOUGH GUY,
EX-MILITARY.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA DO IT.
I JUST -- YOU'RE NOT GONNA
DO IT IN THE TIME FRAME
THAT I WANT TO DO IT IN.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
Greiner: I DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH
ABOUT WHAT MEN CARRY AROUND.
BUT I DO KNOW THAT,
IN ALL MY YEARS IN RETAIL
AND ON QVC
AND CREATING PRODUCTS,
THE HARDEST THING IS
WHEN THERE'S JUST A TON
OF COMPETITION
AND YOU'RE NOT EVEN SURE HOW
POPULAR THE MARKET IS FOR IT.
AND WE'RE NOT SURE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
BUYING THE PRODUCT.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
VERY WELL.
I WISH YOU
ALL THE BEST, THOUGH.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH.
GOOD LUCK, AARON.
GOOD LUCK.
THANKS.
John: GOOD LUCK.
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO IS THAT
THEY DIDN'T LIKE MY VALUATION.
I'M SURE THEY WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE 70% OF THE BUSINESS
FOR 20 GRAND.
AND, YOU KNOW, I LOOKED FORWARD
INTO THE FUTURE,
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S GONNA BE
WORTH A LOT MORE
BECAUSE I'M GONNA MAKE IT WORTH
A LOT MORE.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A MILITARY COUPLE
WITH WHAT THEY BELIEVE
IS THE ULTIMATE MANLY GIFT.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ELI CRANE.
I'M HIS WIFE, JEN.
OUR BUSINESS
IS BOTTLE BREACHER.
WE ARE SEEKING $150,000
FOR 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR BUSINESS.
AT BOTTLE BREACHER, WE MAKE
THE FINEST PERSONALIZED
.50-CALIBER BOTTLE OPENERS
ON THE MARKET.
YOU MIGHT BE ASKING YOURSELF,
"WHY WOULD ANYBODY WANT
A .50-CALIBER BOTTLE OPENER?"
SHORT ANSWER IS,
"THEY'RE AWESOME."
[ LAUGHS ]
AS A FORMER NAVY S.E.A.L.,
I KNEW I NEEDED
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY
WHEN I GOT OUT OF THE NAVY.
BOTTLE BREACHER HAS GIVEN US
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY
REALLY SIMPLE.
MOST GUYS
LIKE DRINKING BEER.
MOST GUYS THINK
THAT LARGE-CALIBER BULLETS
ARE VERY COOL.
AT BOTTLE BREACHER,
WE'VE COMBINED THE TWO
TO CREATE
THE ULTIMATE MANLY GIFT.
WE'VE MANAGED TO CREATE
A SUCCESSFUL COMPANY,
BUT WE KNOW,
WITH YOUR HELP,
WE CAN BREACH THIS THING
WIDE OPENED.
[ HERJAVEC CHUCKLES ]
WE MADE
EACH ONE OF YOU GUYS
A PERSONALIZED .50-CALIBER
BEER-BOTTLE OPENER.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
WE BROUGHT YOU GUYS
SOME BEER.
MR. CUBAN, WE FOUND SOME
GLUTEN-FREE BEER FOR YOU.
I'LL TAKE IT.
Jen:
ROBERT, WE HAVE A RACECAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
Herjavec:
OH, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I LIKE THAT.
Jen: YES.
IT'S GREAT.
LORI, THAT'S THE FIRST PINK
BREACHER WE'VE EVER MADE,
IN YOUR HONOR.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND 'CAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO BE RUDE
AND HAVE YOU GUYS
DRINK ALONE...
Cuban:
YOU NEVER DRINK ALONE.
...I'M GONNA HAVE A DRINK
WITH YOU GUYS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, ELI.
CHEERS.
Cuban: CHEERS.
CHEERS, GUYS.
O'Leary: SO, ELI,
IS IT A REAL .50 CAL?
MR. WONDERFUL,
THAT IS A DUMMY ROUND.
WE USE RECYCLED BULLETS.
WE ARE BUYING
THROUGH AN INTERMEDIATE,
SO THAT'S ONE PLACE WE KNOW,
IN THE FUTURE,
WE CAN ABSOLUTELY
SLASH OUR COSTS
BY GOING DIRECTLY
TO THE MANUFACTURER.
WHERE DO YOU SELL IT?
Jen: WELL,
WE SELL THEM ONLINE.
WE HAVE A ETSY STORE, AND
THEN WE HAVE OUR OWN WEBSITE.
ON AVERAGE,
THEY ARE $23.50.
OKAY.
THEY HAVE
A PRETTY WIDE RANGE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF ADD-ONS,
SO WE CAN ALWAYS ADD-ON
TO THE CUSTOMER.
WHAT ARE THE ADD-ONS?
A ROUND IN, LIKE, BRASS
WOULD START AT $20.
YOU CAN ADD ON ENGRAVING
FOR $5.
YOU CAN ADD A BOX FOR $5.
YOU CAN DO DOUBLE-SIDE
ENGRAVINGS,
WHICH IS AN EXTRA $4.
WHAT'S THE PRICE
YOU'RE PAYING FOR EACH ON?
THE COST TO US,
AFTER LABOR, IS $9.03.
MM-HMM. YES.
SO, UM --
O'Leary: BUT YOU'RE NOT SELLING
TO RETAIL, RIGHT?
NOT -- NOT AT THIS POINT,
SIR.
NOT AT THIS POINT.
WE ARE IN TWO STRATEGIC
BRICK-AND-MORTAR STORES.
OKAY, SO, YOU'RE SELLING THEM
NOW AT WHAT?
WE USUALLY SELL THEM
BETWEEN $16 TO $18.
OUR BIGGEST MARKET
IS WEDDINGS.
WEDDINGS?
IT IS A GROOMSMAN GIFT.
FATHER OF THE BRIDE,
USHERS, GROOMSMEN, BEST MAN --
THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
ANYONE WE CAN GET
IN THE WEDDINGS
BECAUSE THEY'RE WILLING
TO PAY MORE MONEY.
YOU SAID YOU CREATED SOMETHING
FROM SCRATCH.
IT'S A REAL BUSINESS NOW.
GIVE IT TO US
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
YEAR TO DATE, WE'VE MADE
A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
WOW.
AND --
ALL ONLINE,
OR THROUGH RETAIL, OR HOW?
ALL ONLINE.
AND WE'RE PROJECTED
TO END AT $840,000.
WE JUST STARTED JANUARY
OF LAST YEAR.
THAT FIRST MONTH,
WE ONLY MADE $375,
AND LAST MONTH WAS OUR BIGGEST
MONTH EVER AT $100,000.
GOOD JOB, GUYS.
THAT'S AWESOME.
ANSWER WHY IT'S CALLED
"BOTTLE BREACHER."
Eli: YES, SIR.
I'D LOVE TO ANSWER.
A BREACHER IS AN OPERATOR
WHOSE JOB IT IS TO GET US --
THE ASSAULTERS INTO WHATEVER
TARGET WE'RE HITTING.
Cuban:
GOES IN FIRST, RIGHT?
SO YOU GOT THAT BIG OLD DOOR --
YES, SIR.
WHETHER IT'S A SLEDGEHAMMER,
WHETHER IT'S A STRIP-CHARGE
EXPLOSIVE ON THE DOOR,
HE IS THE BREACHER.
THAT'S A QUALIFICATION
LIKE "SNIPER."
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOT TO BREACH
INTO THAT BEER SOMEHOW, RIGHT?
YOU GOT TO GET IN THERE.
YOU GOT TO BREACH.
BOTTLE BREACHER.
AND OUR CUSTOMER BASE,
WE FOUND, LOVES IT.
Herjavec:
THAT'S A GREAT STORY.
THEY LOVE IT.
Greiner: CAN THIS BE MADE
IN OTHER BULLETS?
YEAH.
YES, MA'AM.
THAT'S
A 20-MILLIMETER ROUND.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WOULD FIRE OUT
OF, LIKE, AN ATTACK HELICOPTER
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
SO...
SO THIS IS LIKE --
Herjavec: OH!
OH, MY GOSH.
Cuban: OH, YEAH.
THIS IS THE MOTHER
OF ALL BULLETS.
John: OH, YEAH.
NOW YOU'RE TALKING.
COMPARE.
WE ACTUALLY CALL THAT
THE WMD --
THE WEAPON
OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
YOU GET ANY RESISTANCE
BECAUSE IT'S A BULLET?
BECAUSE SOME MERCHANDISERS
DON'T LIKE THE THOUGHT
OF A BULLET BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN, IN OUR SOCIETY...
NO.
...PROBLEMS AND ISSUES
WITH BULLETS AND GUNS.
NO.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND, YOU KNOW,
TO THAT POINT, WE --
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY PROBLEMS
SO FAR, YOU KNOW,
PUSHING THESE ALONG
THROUGH THE MARKET.
AND WE FOUND THAT MOST PEOPLE,
YOU KNOW, THEY SEE IT
AS A DISPLAY PIECE
AND NOTHING --
NOTHING REALLY HARMFUL.
Jen: THAT'S WHERE THE STORE'S
COMING FROM.
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM, LORI.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
I MEAN, IT'S A REALITY.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD ANYONE
BE LIKE, "OH, I HATE THAT."
WELL, LIKE,
THEN DON'T BUY IT.
O'Leary: WHERE DO YOU NEED
TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY?
LET'S SAY THIS IS A HUGE HIT
ON "SHARK TANK"
AND YOU GET AN ORDER
FOR 50,000 UNITS.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA DO IT?
I KNOW AT THAT NUMBER,
I'M GONNA HAVE TO LEASE
ANOTHER INCUBATOR SPACE.
I'M ALSO GONNA
HAVE TO GET --
IS THAT WHAT YOU NEED
THE $150,000 FOR?
YES, SIR. THAT --
PART OF IT.
AS WE GROW, WE COULD DOUBLE
IN SIZE RIGHT NOW
IN THE SPACE
THAT WE'RE IN.
BUT IF IT STARTS
GOING BIGGER THAN THAT --
INSIDE THAT SPACE,
WHAT DO YOU NEED TO BUY?
OKAY, SO, WE NEED
MORE ENGRAVERS.
EVERY -- YOU KNOW, 90%
OF OUR ORDERS ARE CUSTOMIZED.
WHAT STOPS ANYBODY ELSE
FROM DOING THIS?
OKAY, THAT'S --
AND THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
AND WE DO HAVE
COMPETITION.
THANKS
TO MR. WONDERFUL HERE,
WE WERE ACTUALLY WATCHING
AN EPISODE OF "SHARK TANK,"
AND MR. WONDERFUL
WAS RIPPING APART
AN ENTREPRENEUR
BECAUSE HE --
HE NEVER DOES THAT.
Greiner: TYPICAL DAY.
...HE DID NOT BRAND
ON HIS PRODUCT,
AND AS SOON
AS IT LEFT THE PACKAGE,
YOU COULDN'T TELL IT
FROM THE OTHER ONES.
AFTER THE EPISODE,
I LOOKED AT JEN,
AND I WAS LIKE, "HEY, BABE.
"WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO STAMP 'BOTTLE BREACHER'
ON EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THESE."
SO WE DID.
HE STAYED UP SO LATE.
O'Leary: WELL, I THINK THE NAME
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH SUCCESS.
IT'S CATCHY -- LIKE,
BREACHING AND OPENING.
Herjavec: YEAH,
IT'S A VERY GOOD NAME.
Eli: THANK YOU, SIR.
I MEAN, THAT'S HALF THE BATTLE.
Cuban: GIVE US
THE NAVY S.E.A.L. STORY.
YOU KNOW, I'M SO, SO HONORED
AND HUMBLED TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE WITH THE GUYS
THAT I GOT TO SERVE WITH
THE LAST EIGHT, NINE YEARS.
I DID THREE COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS
TO IRAQ.
THE FIRST TIME I WENT
TO S.E.A.L. TRAINING,
I DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH.
I ACTUALLY MADE IT
THROUGH THE HARDEST PORTION
OF S.E.A.L. TRAINING,
WHICH IS CALLED HELL WEEK,
AND THAT'S 5 DAYS
OF JUST GETTING YOUR BUTT KICKED
THE WHOLE TIME.
NO SLEEP WHATSOEVER, YOU'RE
COLD, WET, AND YOU'RE SANDY,
AND YOU'RE JUST GETTING
BEAT DOWN THE WHOLE TIME.
I MADE IT
THROUGH THAT WEEK.
ABOUT A WEEK
AND A HALF LATER,
THE INSTRUCTORS PULLED ME
INTO THEIR OFFICE,
AND THEY SAID, "YOUNG MAN,
Y-YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE HEART,
"BUT YOU'RE NOT
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
"AND WE NEED THE BEST
OF THE BEST HERE,
SO WE'RE GONNA SEND YOU OUT
TO THE FLEET."
I WAS ON A SHIP
FOR 2 YEARS.
IT WASN'T VERY FUN AT ALL.
Herjavec: WOW.
BUT I-I -- YOU KNOW,
I DID WHAT I HAD TO DO.
I PAID ATTENTION.
YOU KNOW,
AND 2 YEARS LATER,
I CAME BACK,
AND I MADE IT THROUGH.
AND I-I WANTED
TO TELL YOU GUYS THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHO JENNIFER
AND I ARE.
WE DON'T GIVE UP.
YOU KNOW, LIFE IS FULL
OF OBSTACLES AND FAILURES,
AND WHEN WE FACE THAT,
WE DON'T RUN FOR THE HILLS.
WE JUST KEEP CHARGING ON,
AND WE FIGURE IT OUT.
SO, DO YOU DO ANY WEDDING SHOWS
OR ANYTHING?
WE HAVEN'T YET.
JUST BECAUSE, HONESTLY,
WHEN HE WAS ACTIVE DUTY,
I WAS AT HOME,
RUNNING THE BUSINESS.
WE WANTED TO WAIT TO EXPAND
TILL HE GOT OUT,
WHICH IS NEXT MONTH.
I JUST QUIT GOING IN
TO MY NAVY JOB TWO MONTHS AGO.
IT'S TWO-FOLD.
WHEN HE WAS DEPLOYED,
I HAD A REALLY TOUGH TIME,
AND THAT'S WHY I STARTED WORKING
ONLINE BY MYSELF AT NIGHT,
BECAUSE I WAS -- I WAS LONELY,
AND I WAS BY MYSELF.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYONE
IN SAN DIEGO.
AND I GOT USED TO IT,
AND IT'S BEEN
A WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE.
AFTER THREE DEPLOYMENTS,
IT'S NOW TIME FOR HIM
TO COME HOME.
WE HAVE TWO GIRLS.
THEY ASK ABOUT DADDY.
AND, UM --
AWW.
NO, THEY DO.
AND THEY -- AND THEY MISS HIM.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, LOOK.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I LIKE THE STORY.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
I'VE MADE MONEY WITH MILITARY
GUYS 'CAUSE THEY'RE FOCUSED.
I'LL DO IT FOR 20%.
STRAIGHT EQUITY.
WOW.
THAT'S -- THAT --
I'M HONORED TO GET
THAT OFFER FROM YOU, SIR.
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, NO, NO.
I REALLY AM.
YOU KNOW WHY?
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D GET AN OFFER
LIKE THAT FROM YOU.
NO, NO, NO, LISTEN.
I LIKE YOUR STORY.
THAT -- THAT'S AWESOME.
I LIKE -- LISTEN,
I STRUCTURE MY DEALS
BASED ON THE RISK I'M TAKING,
AND I THINK THIS BUSINESS
CAN BE GROWN.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THAT OFFER, AND I'D LIKE --
OUT OF RESPECT
FOR THE OTHER SHARKS,
I'D LIKE TO HEAR IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER OFFERS BEFORE WE --
WELL, LET'S HEAR
IF THEY'RE INTERESTED.
Greiner: YOU ARE WONDERFUL.
Cuban: YOU'RE GOOD.
OUT OF RESPECT TO US,
YOU WANT TO HEAR OUR OFFERS.
YES, MA'AM.
I-I WANT TO HEAR IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER OFFERS OUT THERE.
WELL, RESPECT TO HIM
AS WELL.
WELL, LISTEN.
I LIKE YOU.
YOU HAVE A NICHE MARKET.
BUT I PERSONALLY -- I LIKE
BIG MARKETS, AND SO I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU
$200,000 FOR 25%.
BUT IT WOULD BE CONTINGENT
THAT I CAN GET THE LICENSES.
I WAS ALREADY THINKING
KEY RINGS AND PAPERWEIGHTS
AND A LOT OF OTHER THINGS,
AND I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO RAMP UP
THAT QUICK,
AND I DON'T WANT THE KNOCK-OFFS
OUT THERE IN THE WORLD
TO KNOCK YOU OFF
AND GO DO IT THEMSELVES.
Herjavec: ELI, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT IT TAKES
LIKE A S.E.A.L. DOES.
$150,000 FOR 20% FROM KEVIN,
$200,000 FOR 25% FROM DAYMOND.
I'M GONNA CLEAR THE FIELD
SO YOU CAN CONSIDER THOSE.
I'M OUT.
MARK, WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED
IN GOING IN
WITH EITHER
OF THE OTHER SHARKS?
I'D BE INTERESTING
IN GOING IN WITH KEVIN.
OKAY.
SO, MARK, DO YOU JUST WANT
TO SPLIT IT $75,000 EACH?
YEAH, WE'LL JUST -- YEAH,
YEAH, WE'LL JUST SPLIT IT.
10 POINTS EACH?
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
SO, IF -- LET US SPLIT IT.
THAT'LL WORK.
O'Leary:
SO IT'S $150,000 FOR 20%.
MARK AND I EACH GET 10%.
YES, SIR.
SO WE'RE EACH GONNA PUT IN
$75,000.
YOU GOT TWO SHARKS,
NO CONTINGENCY.
WE'RE GOING STRAIGHT IN.
WE GO RIGHT TO WORK.
MR. CUBAN, MR. WONDERFUL,
YOU GUYS ARE AWESOME!
LET'S DO IT!
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT.
YES!
Jen: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
Cuban: WHY ARE YOU
STANDING HERE? GO TO WORK.
ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL.
O'Leary: GET ON IT.
THANKS, GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
AND THANKS FOR THE BEER.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: THANK YOU
FOR THE BULLET.
Eli: I TOLD JEN
FROM THE GET-GO,
I WANTED
TO LAND TWO SHARKS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A SAYING
IN THE MILITARY --
"ONE IS NONE, TWO IS ONE."
WE WANTED TWO SHARKS,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE GOT TODAY.
ABSOLUTELY THRILLED, ESPECIALLY
WITH THE TWO THAT WE GOT.
IT'S JUST PERFECT.
YEAH.
REALLY WAS.